[Music]
Jason tummy there was a for a while a
Jason Bateman calm yeah and you'd think
okay if I go on Jason Bateman calm I'm
going to learn about colonics
yeah it's that exactly and you're gonna
get to talk or chat with Jason Bateman
but no Jason Bateman calm for quite a
while was a gay porn site explain
explain that I think any explanations
necessary sense to me yeah not to you
yeah yeah no problem
it it was worse than it than a than a
gay porn that was a gay porn hub who was
from from here you could go to thousands
of gay porn sites which you know is fine
some of my best friends Conan but but
you know finish that says all right well
people know the rest yeah dot but
somebody brought this to my attention
and I thought well we should go try to
see if we can change that right I mean
nothing against the the traffic there
but let's see if we can but it's you're
AB that domain yeah they're clearly
using your name against you know why
yeah I don't know what why me why not
why not the hydrated Rob Lowe yeah
exactly I don't get it
so what'd you do I wouldn't let it go
yeah did you buy the site me
I bought the side I now receive a lot of
the income there but I didn't get rid of
the it's still important hub I'm a
businessman the money's coming in we've
the graphics are much more tasteful now
yeah yeah it's a more pleasant
experience for people all right I'm
gonna check it out tonight
Zootopia you play as news not gonna like
that transition
[Music]
with some reduced Amedda ting we'll work
on it no no they're not anything that no
so gay porn and we'll Disney Walt Disney
you